une quarantaine de pompiers et une
équipe du smur un hélicoptère du samu
un dispositif important pour secourir
les trois blessés de cette explosion
la victime la plus grièvement touchée a
été évacué sur l'hôpital des grands
brûlés de précis en région parisienne le
maire de saint julien du sault s'est
rendu rapidement sur le site de l'usiné
soprema il confirme l'origine
accidentelle de l'explosion une
entreprise de maintenance a travaillé
chez le premier une entreprise
extérieure
travailler chez soprema à la maintenance
d'une chaudière vraisemblablement et là
ils ont utilisé une disqueuse à
proximité d'un lieu de stockage de
produits solvants l'afad dissolvant plus
exactement très inflammable et
vraisemblablement une étincelle de la
disqueuse a provoqué cet incendie
brusque ici à saint-julien-du-sault fort
logiquement impossible de pénétrer sans
autorisation sur ce site industriel
dangereux classés seveso
mais la direction que nous avons
contacté à plusieurs reprises n'a pas
souhaité communiquer sur cet accident
selon la préfecture de l'yonne pas de
risque pour la population
le feu qui a suivi l'explosion a été
rapidement maîtrisé mais cette usine a
déjà connu trois incidents en 2012 2016
et 2017
malgré tout les services de l'état se
veulent rassurants on va continuer à
avoir un oeil particulièrement vigilants
sur cette entreprise on la suit de très
près on a un excellent travail avec elle
en collaboration avec les pompiers du
département de l'yonne on travaille bien
avec eux malheureusement ce nouvel
épisode nous appellent à maintenir notre
niveau de vigilance et nous avions
justement une visite qui était prévue à
la fin du mois de juin
on va bien entendu la procureure de la
république de sens à d'ores et déjà
ouvert une enquête pour connaître les
circonstances exactes de cet accident